bonjour monsieur merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin alors après les vives
réactions du ministre des affaires
étrangères de jersey la france a précisé
ce matin qu'elle souhaitait réduire et
n'ont pas coupé l'électricité sur l'île
de jersey c'est un rétropédalage de la
part du gouvernement selon vous une
manière d'apaiser les tensions
je pense bonjour à toutes et à tous je
pense que c'est une manière d'apaiser
les tensions les bien évident que les
détentions ne sont pas favorables à à
régler les problèmes aujourd'hui ce qui
nous importe c'est que l'accord qui a
été trouvé en décembre de l'année
dernière soit appliquée
alors vous avez justement rencontré
récemment nicolas girardin la ministre
de la mer pour lui faire part de vos
demandes à savoir l'octroi des taux d de
toutes les laissant de toutes les
licences aux pêcheurs français l'accord
qui a été signé entre les deux parties
alors aujourd'hui savent lors qu'on sait
que la ministre de la mer va rencontrer
à bruxelles les ministres européens de
la pêche ensuite le commissaire européen
en charge de la pêche à bruxelles est ce
que finalement aujourd'hui
bruxelles peut jouer le rôle d'arbitré
dans cette danse et tensions
c'est effectivement à la commission de
faire appliquer l'accord qui a été
trouvé en décembre de l'année dernière
et c'est ce que les nouvelles chaires
attendent le gouvernement français
cherchait son travail il a élaboré les
listes et il a vérifié que chaque liste
était étayée par des éléments de preuve
aujourd'hui la décision du royaume uni
de ne pas délivrer la totalité des
licences nous interpelle et il me semble
que c'est à la commission désormais
d'utiliser les moyens de rétorsion qui
sont prévues par l'accord
justement quels sont ses moyens de
rétorsion qui sont prévues à part cet
accord européen il ya un travail
d'identification des différents leviers
qui peuvent être utilisés alors c'est
vrai que dans la presse on a pu lire
couper l'électricité
là on tomberait sans doute dans
l'excellent à la ministre ne souhaite
pas non plus plus de problèmes parce qu
on est aussi bien conscient que vous
paie l'électricité ça peut se traduire
par des des effets indésirables
notamment dans les hôpitaux en revanche
on peut jouer sans doute sur les tarifs
on peut on peut augmenter les tarifs
c'est un moyen de pression on a d'autres
accords qui sont en train d'être
renégocié ses ports ferroviaire on a
aussi des accords qui permettent
d'accueillir des étudiants du royaume
uni chez nous il ya tout un tas de deux
leviers sur lesquels on peut on peut
sans doute agir et justement ces quinze
prochains jours sont normalement
destinés à à l'identifier quelle est
aujourd'hui la conséquence
voilà sur sur le terrain sur les
pêcheurs français
les conséquences en fait c'est un manque
de visibilité dans les îles anglo
normandes
on a tout un tas de pêcheurs qui avaient
l'habitude de fréquenter ces eaux alors
plus ou moins régulièrement d'ailleurs
incertain il travaille pratiquement
toute l'année d'autres je travaille de
manière un peu plus épisodique mais ce
qui est important une entreprise de
pêche qui a des décharges à honorer
chaque mois c'est d'avoir de la
visibilité et de savoir que
il peut continuer à pêcher là où est le
poisson
certaines parties de l'asie
merci beaucoup en tout cas jean luc carl
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur général
du comité national des pêches maritimes
et des élevages marins